so James what's your role here at Khan
Academy no I lead our adoption team so I
work with everyone from big corporations
to individual community members to get
folks to spread Khan Academy everywhere
and what is it like what does that mean
on a day to day basis on a
project-by-project basis well the
project at the moment if the entire
project by project basis at the moment
alone storm and so that means building a
really cool experience that people want
to get involved with and working with
lots of partners to make it happen
what is learn storm well in learn storm
is the hopefully one day going to be the
world's biggest learning challenge at
the moment it's a pilot just in the Bay
Area and it's a challenge that every
student can get involved with not just
the kind of top math students but every
single student and it's designed to not
only kind of stimulate lots of math
learning but also to stimulate the
growth mindset so learning how to learn
and and how do you like how does that
translate on a day to day basis like
what what's your day like goes today
like well today was I bounced between
meetings with the team who are working
on the big learn storm finals event
that's being hosted at Google to working
with a TMT foundation who came by to
talk about maybe helping us scale it in
the future to then talking to a bunch of
volunteers who are going to be helping
out on the day and then talking to you
and Shantanu about things that we have
coming up in the future and and like
what even this pilot what kind of scale
are you already seeing right well this
pilot was designed to be a very small
scale pilot in the Bay Area we based it
on some work out of Ireland where which
was a fantastic program where they
managed to capture 1% of all Irish
students which we when we translated it
to the Bay Area we thought well that's
probably about 13,000 students we got
that in the first week and now we're
over 73,000 students so we have it's
really just taken off and that's what
like seven or eight
the eligible students yeah yeah like
about about 8% we're hoping to you know
to go even higher next to it and what
else says so so learn storm that's part
of adoption it's pilot it's something we
it seems like it's very successful
probably going to expand in different
ways well what else what else do you
work on well yeah I mean if taking that
to the to the national and international
stage isn't enough we also have the next
big project on the on the docket is the
SAT college board partnerships so coming
soon actually at the beginning of June
we're going to be launching the first
ever free s8 official SAT test prep
product which is content from the
College Board and an experience from
Khan Academy an interactive personalized
experience so the question is you know
how can we get as many people as
possible learning this and using it and
you know how can we help schools and
libraries and everyone offer this to
students everywhere and and what you
know kind of what makes someone good at
what you do hmm
I think it's something I've been
thinking about a bit I think you need a
combination of three things and I don't
think not necessarily talking about
myself but as I think about people to
join the team here's what I'm thinking
about first creative strategy so you
need to be able to think with both the
right brain and come up with crazy ideas
or you know work out the next lone storm
but also be structured and be able to
kind of break that down into all of the
thousands of problems you need to solve
in order to make something like that
happen the second thing though you need
is the ability to work operationally so
it's not enough to come up with a
strategy on paper but you actually need
to turn that into a reality and that
involves kind of plans and systems and
working with lots of different partners
and people and keeping them all in line
and moving forward and then I think the
third thing you need is a bit of a bit
of sales a bit of a Salesman tality a
bit of like the ability to talk to
people and and help convince them that
what you're doing is really cool and and
I think if you've got all three of those
things and I want you on my team and
what were you doing before this well I
was back in Australia back in the day I
had my
kind of startup actually in the
education space I sold that it was a
McKinsey and company for quite a few
years and then when I came over to the
United States I worked for a group
called purpose about in New York who do
online political mobilization and then
when I came to the West Coast my wife
and I'm kind of converged on the west
coast of the United States and spoke to
you and came here and then we hired her
to and then we hide her - yeah I had
nothing to do with that that was I mean
obviously and and you know you've been
here a little bit now yeah like two and
a half years almost well what what
surprised you about the experience I
think it feels amazing to be at the
center of things that are changing it
didn't surprise me it surprised me how
much we that is really true that the
network of Khan Academy the people who
we get to talk to I mean we're a small
start-up but I think we sometimes are
able to punch with a much above that
weight because they're you know people
who believe in us and people who really
want us to do well and the amount of
positivity behind Khan Academy I think
would surprise anyone like when you meet
the the kind of students who are working
or you meet like the people from big
corporations who want to help out it's
it's just that level of positivity I
hoped was here because I certainly felt
it but I think it's definitely out there
in the world and you know Lauren storm
is one thing but what are you most
excited about in the near term and even
a little bit further out oh and I think
what I'm most excited about is scaling
up our ability to do things like learn
storm I think Khan Academy has this
incredible product team you know able to
make magic happen
I think we have an amazing team on the
on the program side too but I think
we've traditionally built products and
let them speak for themselves and that's
been great it's it's it's you know gone
a huge way but I think what we have the
opportunity to do is create context for
those products to be used in and whether
it's the SAT or whether it's learn storm
whether it's something else I'm really
what I'm most excited about doing is
just making sure as many people as
possible can can use Khan Academy by
doing things like that yeah I'm with you
well thanks for being part of this
adventure it's been an honor thank you
thanks for having me